and welcome to the 30th ever episode of
the
iced coffee hour my name is james and we
have made
23 249 and 61 cents to date
wow that was good did i nail it you name
it you're the first person to ever read
the analytics while doing it
but you did very very well thank you so
much of course yeah thanks for having me
yeah thank you so much
so we came all the way to utah to do
this episode
so if that doesn't deserve a like i
don't know what does because you just
bought a bugatti
i did 31 years old i did yes wait we
can't say we can't say getting
doing so well we don't want to say the k
word no no
no no so thanks so much for coming on
the podcast we really appreciate it yeah
thanks so much for having me
thanks for coming to visit me so explain
really quick
what you do what your business is how
you were able to buy bugatti at 31 years
old
going from this you started living in
your car
yeah yeah so my name is james i run a
youtube channel
the strad man i made up that name when i
was probably 14 or 15 years old
dream car was the ferrari challenge
stradali so it's a play officer dolly
so start off the youtube channel film
and cars car spotting
and then got a real job for a while but
continued the car spotting
bought a lamborghini channel took off
bought some more cars bought a jeep
continued to grow yep and then i decided
it felt right to buy a bugatti
but really the only reason i could buy
it
is because of my youtube channel it's
the ultimate justification tool
you know because i can drive it i can
film content with it every single
every single time i drive that car i'm
making money i'm filming videos i'm
doing instagram stuff i'm doing tick
tock stuff
so i'll be at an expensive car to
operate
the money that i make offsets it you
know what got you into cars
i have loved cars since before i can
remember time
like i've just always been there the
passion's always been there and i've
always loved photography
and so i've always had a camera in hand
and
i've wanted to take photos of cars so
even when you were like
four or five you had a fascination with
christ and it just stuck with you all
the way till now
i have pictures of me as like a
five-year-old standing in front of a
lamborghini countach
you know that's awesome like dupont
registry is a magazine
that has like amazing cars for sale and
i remember i'd go to like the local
grocery store
and i'd go to the magazine section to
see the dupont registry and i just
flipped through it looking at all these
cars for sale
and i'd find oh there's this dealership
in portland oregon
and i beg my parents whenever we went to
portland to go to this car dealership
and so one of those photos in front of
the countach was from that so i've just
the passion's always been
there and uh why haven't you gotten to
challenge
stradale yet of all the cars right right
right pick the one that you're named
after well
dreams change over time and so when i
was 14 years old the challenger dolly
was my my favorite car in the world
but now that i'm in a position where i
can actually afford
you know a car of that magnitude my
favorite car in the world is the
lamborghini aventador
and there's two of them parked behind us
so it's mainly just dreams changed when
i made up the name obviously the name
stuck
that being said i still think the car is
amazing and someday i'll buy one yeah
for sure
i would bet in the next like year and a
half got it so it's coming soon what was
the first car you got
first car that i bought with my own
money was a 2
000 volkswagen passat wagon how much was
that six thousand bucks
how did you get the money so when i was
10 years old i got a paper route and i
was a paper boy for
a number of years earned some money and
then in high school i worked at
a candy store called goodies in bend
oregon
made i don't know eight bucks at eight
bucks an hour and then when i was in
college i had a couple internships
working for the oregon department of
transportation those jobs actually paid
decent
for the time and i just didn't spend any
money because cars have always been my
love
and so i basically saved up all the
money that i earned from those four
career
careers professions professionals
thank you thank you graeme okay uh and i
took all that money to buy my passat and
what made you decide that car
specifically
i kind of sort of got talked into it by
my parents because it was like the
ultimate
moment yeah there's a wagon car back to
a high school with
with tan interior yeah so i got talked
into it
and it was a nice car don't get me wrong
like it was a nice car and then about
10 months later um my girlfriend and i
broke up at the time we broke up and
i guess i had my midlife crisis and i
saw i sold the basalt wagon and i went
and i bought a sports car
is that the audi audi tt 2002 quattro
2.5 horsepower
i would have been a sophomore in college
when i bought that yeah that's a decent
cost for sophomores yeah it was 13 800
bucks
okay i financed i would have financed uh
what maybe eight thousand bucks of it
and put down you know 5 800 or so
what made you want to get a paper route
so your parents too was that your mom
oh yeah oh yeah so i have three older
brothers okay and they all were paper
boys as well
and so growing up like my parents
wouldn't buy me anything they'd buy me
the necessities
clothes food you know once a year before
school we'd go get school supplies and
then christmas of my birthday that was
it
anything else if i wanted grand theft
auto they weren't going to buy it for me
i had to buy it myself
and i saw my older brothers with their
paper outs you know and they were able
to buy stuff
and so i basically was like well that's
how you make money and i think i made 10
cents per newspaper delivered
and i had i think 36 newspapers to
deliver every day
so i made uh 3.60 every day you know
what kids are doing now
it's those uh magazine subscriptions at
school
is that a thing yeah i don't even
remember that that school brings that
though
yeah school school does that so what
they do is they'll come in
and they'll say if you want to sell
these newspapers or sorry if you want to
sell these magazines to your like
friends and family and neighbors
if you sell 20 magazine subscriptions
we'll give you this reward we'll give
you a fidget spinner yes
yeah you could win like candy and like
like all these things that
allowed with child labor laws i don't
know sixth grade i did that
uh and the top prize was a limo
drive to get pizza i kid you not
and i wanted nothing more than just to
do that
and i kid you not i sold enough magazine
subscriptions i don't know
and you got it no my dad took it into
his work i think my dad did most of the
work before
yeah he went into his work and i think
he peddled this magazine
some sort of subscription there's
something you had to sign up for right
right uh and i think i got like the 20
needed or whatever
and it was like lunch time on a tuesday
a limo pulls up in front of school
you're the coolest
in school it was like me and seven other
kids and we all got a limo and
uh pizza is so cool that's the ultimate
motivation congratulations it's been a
winner since day one
if you ever want to relive that i don't
know if you saw the rolls-royce limo
outside the house i saw that but like if
you need to take for a spin
let me know that would be fun to get
pizza yeah we'll even sell it to you
relive the glory days gosh
why did you buy that car oh so explain
what was in the state
what is that it was a mistake is what it
was so as a youtuber
there are moments of weakness in your
life when you're
struggling for content and for me living
here in utah
january i think for every youtuber
january is like
you know you've been hustling you know
to earn that december ad revenue january
comes around and you're just like oh
what do i do
so late one night january last year
sitting on the couch
my buddy nick burlacker he's sitting on
the couch and i'm looking at buying a
rolls royce drop head coupe
which is like a newer rolls-royce
convertible it's just like it's the most
ridiculous car
and i would just i do not belong in a
rolls-royce phantom drop a coupe
so i was going to buy one and then i was
scrolling and i found this rolls-royce
limo
and somehow we came up with the idea
that it'd be smart for me
for i came up with the idea to buy it
i'd get some content out of it and then
i would gift it
to nick to help his channel and then he
would be able to use the limo
and take it out on uber rides and we'd
bury it and
you know cut the roof off and turn it
into a hot tub and just like do silly
stupid nonsense this is what happened in
january
and so we we went through with it i
bought that thing for
twenty thousand dollars how is it so
cheap what year is it
i was thinking how is it so expensive
does it run well
it runs decent yeah it runs okay it's
luxurious
it's not i mean so in 1982 it was
effectively the most expensive car money
could buy like when you think of it
think of a brand new rolls royce today
like a rolls royce cullinan
this was the equivalent but this was the
limousine how much was it what was the
msrp
um i think it was about 150 000.
so back in 1982 600
yeah yeah which is what a new role
choices
it's a factory limo there's only 16 of
them in the world so how is it 20 000
wouldn't you say that's like it's a
rolls royce
only 16 of them yeah it's rare yeah
collectible
here you are let's put a hot tub in it
would that's why we didn't do it
the reason we didn't cut the roof off
and do everything is because we felt
guilty because i'm a car guy through and
through
and for me to just like trash this
somewhat collectible car
seemed wrong you know it's just because
the card does have some value to the
right person
and i just don't know who the right
person is to buy it off of us
but how is it 20k how does the card
depreciate that much there's probably
such a
few like such little demand for it yeah
i mean would you want a 1982 rules
versus limo like what would you do with
that what was what would the mo
what would the majority people do with
that
it is so like large
it's large and convenient it's an
eyesore too you know sitting in front of
the house it leaks
oil it's just like it's just and you
know it's speed
it's not great what about this burying
it i heard a story
were you telling me that you're going to
bury it we did bury it why
you're talking about like not putting a
jacuzzi but it's okay to bury it
but first a quick word from our sponsor
vessy don't you guys hate it when you're
crying because you don't have a
girlfriend and your
tears drip onto your shoes and get your
socks all wet
well fortunately for you vessy is here
vessy makes these amazing waterproof
shoes that will always be sure to keep
your feet dry
even in the harshest conditions not only
that but the shoes that they sent me i
wear them all the time
they're comfy enough for me to go on my
walks in and stylish enough for me to
visit the family in
they really are a great pair of shoes i
just leave my vests by the door and feel
confident to throw them on in any kind
of weather and guess what guys you're in
luck
fessy is holding an early holiday sale
so click the link down below
and get 25 off your vessy's and if you
miss out on the sale
use code iced coffee to get 25 off your
new pair of essies so i'm not saying you
have to do it
but if you need a new pair of shoes i
really encourage you guys to get a pair
of sc's because i'm going to be honest i
i genuinely love mine and i wear them
all the time once again check out
s i dot vessi.com slash iced coffee to
get 25
off your new pair of shoes and with that
said you guys back the podcast right
right so when i say
bury it it wasn't a true burial it's
more like we created a tomb
and we put the car in the tomb if that
makes sense so i don't know if you saw
at the house
we have a massive hole in the backyard
that we dug yeah and then we drove the
limo
down in the hole and then we covered the
hole with a bunch of plywood and dirt
and
then we put the plywood over kind of
like a tomb and we left it there
and then we dug it out shortly
thereafter that was for a video it was
for a video yep is that
your idea too uh yeah nick and i kind of
decided to do it together i would do the
video bearing it he would do the video
unbearing it so be a good collab he'd
get some content i get some content
and the thought process was maybe we
could make this video go viral
pay for the limo so then we wouldn't
feel as bad about buying them
what happened did it go viral no it got
a million views
so it paid for itself yeah i mean it
paid for itself but it didn't it didn't
do anything in access
and i'm not complaining about the views
it just but but here's the the car is
value to it
absolutely so you're ahead now oh yeah
we were at the car
and you got the content out of it so you
made money from it we didn't make money
yep yeah we made money so all in all
from an investment standpoint roi
is actually pretty high it's actually
higher than
most of the cars in here we were talking
to another youtuber carter sharer
and he basically started buying a bunch
of really nice cars because
they provided a better roi than he could
have found anywhere else for his youtube
channel
how many cars have you bought to date
and have you ever had a negative roi
on those cars so every single car
i've had a positive roi by a landslide
like so it's a no-brainer every single
time every single time
the rolls-royce would be i just haven't
filmed that much with it
but from a percentage standpoint it'd
actually be pretty pretty good
yeah every single car every single car
easily and how many cars have you bought
that's a tough question i have eight
cars right now i've sold probably
five or six cars in the past two years
so maybe 14.
let's talk briefly about your living
situation you're living with
nick nick yep is was your boss
he was uh-huh who fired you yeah in a
way in a way yeah okay for youtube he
fired me in real life i got laid off
but youtube views are a lot better when
you say we're fired but yeah so i met
nick
he took a chance on me i worked for him
for a year and a half
company went belly up and then i
went youtube full time i was living in
an apartment up in park city
and it was like six seven hundred bucks
a month and i was
i wanted to go to europe for six weeks
to film videos i was like well i can't
afford rent why i'm gone
so i rented a storage unit put
everything i owned in the storage unit
booked a flight went to europe with
gordon f-spot was there for six weeks
came back from europe and didn't have a
place to live and nick and i had kept in
touch while i was gone he's like dude i
got a spare bedroom
i'll rent it to you for 250 bucks a
month
so here i am like you know trying to
grow my youtube channel
you know trying to keep my expenses at
an all-time low not sure how much i'm
gonna make every month
and nick basically just gives me a room
for free
you know he just gave it for me for free
and it just like all of a sudden i had
no expenses
effectively and that helped me out like
i can't even measure how much that
helped me out
um and then as my channel grew we
started basing my rent off my
subscribers
oh that's yeah a day
now my rent is 30 000 a month he should
have he should have kept
going but he ended up cutting it off so
how did this
how did that work it was a ratio yeah
yeah i want to know so it was it was
subscript so when i
i was paying 250 dollars imagine it in
your videos guys
do not subscribe watch it's gonna freeze
don't subscribe it's gonna cost me so
much money
so when i had 250 000 subs my rent was
250 bucks a month
once it was three hundred thousand i had
three hundred bucks a month
someone want to hit five hundred
thousand so my rent was based off the
number don't you make
so much money off three hundred thousand
thousand dollars for millions
of things right 300 000 subs i wasn't
making very much money
wow youtube rates have gone up so much
shut off sponsorships as well
i didn't get my first sponsored video
until like three hundred thousand subs
and it was like six hundred bucks so how
about that how much were you making back
then
oh i should have done some research it
wasn't
it was equivalent to making like 50
60 000 a year so i was probably making
not bad four or five thousand a month
obviously the nice thing about youtube
is everything's a write-off yeah so
you know i was i was making equivalent
to what i was as an accountant but i had
so many write-offs that helped a ton
right yeah but that was probably around
three hundred thousand subs
i think around six seven hundred
thousand that's when it like took
okay yeah that's when i was like okay
wow i'm making i'm making like legit
money now yeah
you know what what's legit money oh i
mean this was fifteen thousand dollars a
month
that's legitimate no it is it is it is
it is absolutely
you know at that time that was like wow
i'm making six plus figures filming
these dumb youtube videos chasing cars
around the world getting to travel all
the time
have the experiences of a lifetime
making six figures
you know so that was and then it kind of
just took off from there
that's what's so crazy about youtube
it's like you have to work so much
harder at the beginning
in a lot of ways than i do now yet the
rewards
are all now yeah it's just crazy i mean
i guess everything is like that in life
though but
at what subscriber count did the rent
kind of cap
off so i currently pay eight hundred
dollars a month
so it capped at like yeah i guess well
so i was living in his town home at the
time yeah
and then he decided he wanted to buy the
house so he sold his town home bought
the house
i followed him from his town home to his
house and then a year later he got
married i still live with him and then i
got a dog a year later and my dog lives
with us as well you're taking over
i know pretty soon you may as well just
take the master bedroom in the house
yeah but how does that how does that
dynamic work with like him and his wife
and and just you in the house yeah how
how was your relationship with his wife
great okay awesome it really helps that
i have a really really cute dog
yeah because she loves oscar my dog so
much
and i think i think that helps she's
super easy going i'm easygoing
and i think just our personalities just
mesh really well yeah nick and i get
along so well
too that i think she understands that
dynamic
and i think that she sees that
nick is happy having me around so it
makes her happy yeah
and i'm happy being around and so it's
weird it's a weird dynamic but it works
really really well
at least from my perspective you know i
haven't gotten the notice on the door
yet
but you're talking about now moving out
yes
so i am scheduled to break ground on my
house
in january and then as soon as the house
is done they told me nine ten months no
i know and that and i yeah every night
half
a year and a half it's honestly gonna be
a year and a half i know
i would bet you a thousand dollars now a
thousand dollars right now
wow it's gonna be 18 months look at this
guy
i'm going to say from the day you start
whenever that is okay okay it's going to
be a bone right now it's going to be
18 months from the day we break ground
the day you break ground
to the point where construction is
completely done
when i move in like certificate of
occupancy certificate of occupancy
but you can't like you know when the
garage isn't done let's just say but the
house is technically
no no technicalities here the whole of
course of course i am
i'm asleep i am sleeping in my bed
in my house for the first night yes and
i post the video
moving in okay i'm gonna say that's 18
months okay
you say you say how long under 18 months
10 months is what i was told but i also
believe that nothing
ever gets done on time right i'm gonna
say 12 months
okay you say 12 i say 18
right and whoever's closest okay so 15
or under is what i need
yeah okay right done shake on it okay
we'll just do the jack put the little
this is legally
it is legally binding yeah absolutely
thousand bucks thousands usd yeah
dollars yes okay
so make sure you're not gonna throw me
canadian dollars or something
go buy a toothpick no okay okay yeah no
i'm going to say
man i've never gambled in my entire life
i could attest to this
actually we were in vegas that's right
remember
what was this two years ago something
like this and i tried so hard
to have you put one dollar in the salon
and i
think what what like our work around to
this was i it was it gordon
f spot gave you a dollar no no
gordon put the money in the machine and
then had you just press the button for
gordon's money
because you refused to spend any of your
money you wanted to give me you were
like gonna hand me a fifty dollar bill
yeah
because i wanted to play the slot
machine because it was good i was like
why can't we go do something
else with this 50 i couldn't do it
beginner's luck every
everyone who's i don't want to go and
talk about gambling now but i'm just
saying
there is beginner's luck in the casino
if you go in never having done it before
you always win the first time right well
that's what they want you to do right
right exactly and then you never win
ever again of course so you have one
shot where you go
and or or did that not count i don't
think it counted because i definitely
didn't win anything we lost that 50
bucks like that but it wasn't your own
money
okay why are you so against gambling
it's just a waste of money
but not only that but couldn't you find
enjoyment out of it so even if you are
spending money it's like say you go
and you enjoy playing poker and you go
okay that's different and you play for
four hours and you lose a hundred
dollars that's different poker makes
sense because that's actually
entertaining
but slot machines you just push a button
okay i agree with you
i agree yeah yeah but what about card
games like blah blah that would that
would that would you like black jack and
poker so
i have never played any of those games i
don't know how to play them
and so it i don't know i just get
nervous when people invite me to do it
because i don't know how to and i don't
embarrass
myself nobody's actually taking the time
to properly teach me
and so for me to go to vegas and be like
oh i'm going to play it's intimidating
and it's very
very intimidating exactly you got to
learn with anthony we have a friend his
name is ant-man
he was uh a big-time poker player
loves to let this this whole stuff he's
a great teacher
he'll teach you how to play blackjack
that's one of my favorite games and you
don't play
crazy hands you're not gonna play a
hundred dollars of course of course of
course start with five dollars a hand
go in with 50 bucks maximum knowing that
if you play correctly
you're gonna have fun for an hour at a
table with your friends right back and
forth
maybe you win some money maybe you lose
worst case you spend 50 bucks for an
hour of fun with your friends that's
that's the same price as like top golf
right right absolutely thing okay next
time i'm in vegas you're in vegas
anthony's in vegas let's
anthony you can teach yeah anthony where
are you at bro yeah yeah you teach me
deal so anyway glad to know you're
potentially interested in learning about
this but
it's fun that that's that's my uh my
logic behind i mean we've already made a
bet on this podcast i don't know what
what else to expect yes i'm already out
of my my comfort zone but tell us about
the house
and i have some thoughts to share with
you yes uh so the house
uh breaking ground here soon hopefully
so originally the house design
i just wanted it to be a garage a 10 car
garage with a 2 bedroom apartment above
it
but i ran into a bunch of city
ordinances that wouldn't allow that
basically
and so i had to redesign the house and
i need all of i don't need
it's so much nicer if all of my cars are
easily accessible it just makes life
easier you know running over the
warehouse and back like
it just takes up so much time throughout
the day and so having all my cars at the
house one location would just be
life-changing and i've never had that
and so i want you know a house i want to
build a house that
i can put all my cars but then also have
room for growth so i have eight cars
right now
but looking into the future with the
channel there's no reason to think i
won't hit 14
15 cars someday you know i don't past 15
might get a little bit
exhausting but you know 15 cars so the
house design was kind of centered around
that exhaust
get it yeah see what i did there um
wow i completely lost my train of
thought with that bombshell joke from
graham
um so yeah so centered around that
central idea like i need a 15 to 20 car
garage
but if you're building a 15 to 20 car
garage you have to have a house that's
going to be
somewhat matching that because someday
if i want to sell this place
and you have this 20 car garage you know
with a
three-bedroom house next to it like
who's going to want to buy that what
husband and wife are going to see that
and the wife's going to like
give the stamp of approval like yeah
let's buy the like it'd be hard to sell
so i needed a house that was going to
match the garage
so unfortunately that means a you know 6
7 000 square foot house
attached to it um which is not the worst
thing in the world but it's
definitely excessive and the upstairs
will probably never be used
honestly i'm against the house i watched
your video i know
i know i know and i knew originally when
you're talking about
creating this whole garage that you
could live in it's not going to happen
right and resale is going to be terrible
absolutely but you building a house to
match the garage
in my opinion is a is a big financial
mistake
i wouldn't do it but first a quick word
from our sponsor manscaped
being poorly groomed is a thing of the
past it's time to gear up and give
yourself the gift of shaving this
holiday season
i'm talking about the manscaped perfect
package 3.0 it's literally everything
you need to keep trimmed cut free and
smelling nice
inside the perfect package 3.0 you can
find the lawnmower 3.0 which is
manscape's redesigned electric trimmer
it has proprietary advanced skin safe
technology so the trimmer reduces cuts
and can be used in the shower the
manscaped perfect package 3.0 also
includes the crop preserver an
anti-chafing deodorant and moisturizer
that you can use
anywhere i'm also thankful for their
crop reviver this product along with the
crop preserver keeps your applicated
area from sweating
smelling and sticking and these products
smell really nice their manly scent is
super attractive
and will help set the mood the perfect
package will also come with a pair of
manscaped boxers
between you and me it's time for an
upgrade on those undies i know how long
you've had them tis the season to
manscape and if you're struggling
finding a gift for your dad your uncle
your brother
your dog look no further the manscape
perfect package 3.0 is an amazing gift
and you really can't go wrong with it
get 20
off and free shipping with the code iced
coffee at manscape.com
make sure to be well groomed for the
holidays and make santa proud this year
and with that said back to the podcast
if i were you buy a house like a normal
house that you would use
all of and maybe you could throw into
one day right and then invest the money
in a big warehouse
right one day you could rent it out to
people who want to do like
storage or they want to do fulfillment
do they want to make manufacturing in
there yep but a big warehouse
with a whole bunch of open space you
don't need lifts or anything like this
yeah just this times 10. but that's not
cool bro
imagine walking into this empty barren
warehouse with just a bunch of cars in
it and there's nothing to it but that's
not true
you don't build it out right the house
is essentially
it's the walls imagine all the walls and
that's what a garage is yeah but there's
gonna be a car
elevator and cool led lights and like
how much is this
how much is this going to cost so that's
the thing that's everything these are
utah this is a utah house now it's not a
los angeles house
this house in l.a would be like a 10
million house yeah so it's gonna be
1.5 million dollars for the build the
land's 460. so right around a two
million dollar home
which i realize is definitely a very
very nice home and i'm not trying to say
that it's not
but it you know a two million dollar
home in los angeles is nothing right
i mean it's not nothing but like average
it's average yeah whereas here
you know the prices are so much less you
get so much more for your dollar here in
utah
and so two million dollars you know
let's say i get a warehouse that's going
to be
what half a million yes half a million
bucks you buy a house
that's going to be probably 700 000
right
depends on the house area but like but
the thing is
i i don't need but i have
a bugatti and i want to be parked in a
place that's somewhat safe
and so when i look at the utah real
estate you're looking at around a 700
000
house that's roughly so you're looking
at 1.2 million right there
so the difference between what you're
saying and what i'm saying is
eight hundred thousand dollars is that
fair potentially yeah
okay so yeah that is fair that's fair
which is obviously a ton of money
but the other key difference um
i think and this is just a thought this
is an idea
is the home build videos i think are
gonna
crush youtube i think the videos
building the house are gonna
kill it i think they're gonna get double
the views that i normally get
i'm planning to film this entire process
and i think it's gonna be so sick
because
you look at the automotive sphere and
you have all these automotive youtubers
and they're all buying cars they're all
building cars but i'm going to be
building a dream supercar garage which
every single car guy
dreams of so i think that the videos
building the house
will earn crazy amounts of money
so here's what i'm afraid of you're
going to be in 2 million bucks in this
house
for resale it's it's you're not going to
get that back
i i don't think it's
it's such a specific buyer who wants to
buy a house like that
i'm not i want to interrupt you go for
it it's remember it's utah though yes
utah's not los angeles
everybody in utah has a fifth wheel
trailer a motor home
they got side by sides they got dirt
bikes they got trucks they got
trailers they got how many homes sell
for like two million dollars here um
a lot in that area in that area yeah
yeah i mean the area
the area that i'm building in i don't
want to say where it is obviously but
every single
house in this area has a massive
detached garage
like nearly every single house in the
area probably has a 15 to 20. so it's
not an
out of the noise oh no it fits right in
yeah it fits right in
i've seen the renderings of it though i
mean you want like a it's a two-story
garage with with a bridge that connects
to the house
that's a good way to get around the the
the you're not supposed to have a garage
directly like with the door attaching to
it right
a main living area supposed to be a
transition for like fumes and stuff like
that that's a good
way to get around that yeah but i'm
worried that you're gonna be 2 million
bucks
and then for resale it's going to be a
hard sell or you might have to
sell it one six right you know something
like that
and take a loss on it so i see this
house as a place that i plan to live for
a long time
i don't see it as being uh you know in a
year it's like okay i gotta move i see
this as being uh and that's why i'm
building it the way i am
because i want this 15 to 20 car garage
so i see it
you know living there for 10 15 20 years
and i'd be shocked given how utah is
growing yeah
everybody from california is moving to
utah and you got to tell your family
your friends to stay in california even
though you just moved
to vegas proving my point but i'm
telling you the utah
market is just out of control utah and
idaho everybody from california
and the midwest and the east coast is
moving to utah and there's a reason for
it because it's a beautiful place
economy is good like yeah i get it but
so you know home values
as such are are climbing in value so
you're saying even if
it's not worth what you're in it right
matter of time until eventually it will
be
right right right and i and and like i
said i think that the videos
will offset any of the yeah um
depreciation
i would be yeah one more go for it yeah
so i
the price of the house is 1.5 million
i'm working with a lot of companies to
get a lot of free stuff
good and a lot of that free stuff is
going to offset that number
by probably 200
000 if i had to guess that's like my my
my best guess
so that'll offset the depreciation as
well so i'll be in it myself
1.8 even though the average person would
be in it
two so then if i sold it for 1.6
it doesn't hurt as bad considering the
value that you're gonna get out of the
home with the videos that you post on
right right and i
i truly believe that these videos are
gonna help
take me to a different level and add a
whole new demographic
how have your current home videos
performed awesome
really better better than the car videos
you'd say um
views wise about the same okay but i
feel like the interest level
has been really really high and then
when i think about like the home videos
that i'm filming right now are not very
exciting videos it's me just like
walking around on like showing a
walkthrough on a computer whereas i
think the actual like the framing the
house i think that video will do really
really well
um you know just like even the home tour
video
like when i finally move in and i film
that video this is the home tour
there's a chance like we talked about
earlier you can never predict
viral videos there's a chance that video
could get 10 million views and i can
i can earn a hundred thousand dollars
it's totally possible uh when i look
into the future that's a video that i
think could crush it
especially if this garage is how i'm
envisioning it you know the thumbnails
like this
incredible bat cave garage with a car
elevator i got 10 super cars there that
video could get 10 million views
i could make 100 grand off of it i'd be
interesting to see
how this video is performed my
experience my remodel videos
do not do that well yeah they're some of
the worst performing videos
yeah because it doesn't look like things
have to get done of course like
sometimes two months could go by and the
place
looks the same for sure but it's hard to
convey like oh but it's new electrical
in there yeah yeah
there's a roof that's brand new it's
like you can't show that stuff it's it's
not
interesting it's not like the sexy stuff
yep but the people who watch those
videos
love them so you get a small audience
who's really dedicated versus a big
audience for sure so i try to sprinkle
those in every now and then but it's
hard to get those videos to do well
so i'm curious if you're going to have a
different experience than me and i
don't know i mean i don't know the
answer to that question i think that
the storyline of the house should do
pretty well because they'll be watching
it be built from the ground up
like digging the hole to me moving in
whereas your videos you know it's a
remodel
maybe not quite as exciting now like you
said though like
you know digging the hole there'll be a
lot of hype for that because that'll be
like the first construction video
that'll do well
you know pouring the foundation will be
kind of cool the framing i think will do
really really well
once the framing is done the house won't
be changing that much that quickly
those videos might not be quite as
exciting but
i think that um towards the end of the
build the move-in videos i think those
would do really really well
also so we'll kind of sort of see but
i'm excited i'm excited about doing
something that's kind of
different also but still car focused and
it'll add a lot of nice filler content
because a lot of my videos
i'll film like a 12 13 14 minute video
and i'll hit like six or seven different
topics
you know i'll talk two minutes on the
events or two minutes on the bugatti two
minutes on the gtr
go check out the house film two minutes
there so it'll be a nice little like
additional storyline yeah
going along with the rest of the story
one thing i wanted to say about the
difference between his home videos and
your home video
is i think that your home video is more
so just about the financials of the home
and because that's like the main focus
in the video is like the roi
and the amount of money that you're
spending and then what you're getting
for that whereas with your home videos
like you said i think that it's a little
different like it would be more
entertainment based rather than
educational
yep so i think that you're also hitting
like on a bigger
audience demographic whereas graham's
kind of just going towards his usual
audience but it's also just a little bit
more niche since it's
really hardcore focused on real estate
that's true yeah yeah
yeah i mean my videos you will watch my
videos and effectively learn
nothing you watch your videos like it's
information
you know like the amount of information
you get is amazing mine's a total
opposite
you know it's purely just entertainment
it's just something that's like a stress
reliever
yeah so that yeah i definitely think
that there could be a difference there
on the home build videos i don't know
we'll see
yeah i'm kind of excited to see what
it's going to be like um
i feel like home vid home uh build
videos have done actually really well
though
like all like the move-in videos and
stuff like that right yeah those videos
are
always on trending i feel like every
single week you see at least two like
our new home videos i also want to film
one of those videos it's like
i'm gonna film obviously throughout the
process and then at the end i'm going to
make a compilation
video that's like building my house from
start to finish in 12 minutes yep and
it'll start you know the opening clip
is me standing in a dirt lot and then
the final clip is me
you know walking through the garage
those videos always do the best yeah
i did on my remodel yeah they crushed
the entire way yeah it's just okay right
and then that final video i put it all
together in one
yep people love that instantaneous
gratification right
like that's what they want so it makes
sense so i think that video could also
that video could crush too yeah you know
we'll kind of see youtube you know you
can never predict you can never predict
viral videos but yeah
how much strategy do you put in your
videos right now it's like thinking
i want this video to play on this one
and like i'm going to save this video
for this day and like
there's a lot that i do behind the
scenes that i don't think people realize
i see you change
thumbnails a lot oh absolutely you
change thumbnails all the time
that's my favorite is when i'll be
scrolling it'll be like wait a second
this was different like
so change it again i was in jackson hole
wyoming
and i posted a video and it was from the
first lego gold rush rally from seattle
to spokane
posted the video it was doing awful like
just
terrible i think it had like 13 000
views in the first
eight hours or whatever let's say like
they didn't have 10 10 back then
but if they did this video had been like
15 of the 10. like it was just
awful and during that day there was a
bugatti veyron supersport that got
pulled over
by a police officer and i filmed that
happen but that was not the title that
was not the thumbnail of the video was
just a scene
within the video and i changed the title
and the thumbnail to
bugatti veyron pulled over by washington
washington state police and then the
thumbnail was that
instantly in a split second the video
just took off skyward wow like
absolutely insane
and i remember after 24 hours it set a
new record
for the most views i'd ever had in 24
hours although in the first like
however many hours it was like the worst
video and so that was the day i realized
how important titles and thumbnails were
the videos and thumbnails it was really
lame it was like
gold rush rally convoy to whatever like
it was just like
whatever it was it was stupid but this
was back in the day i didn't know what i
was doing right
you know you just didn't and that day it
clicked with me that's when i realized
that a thumbnail title change can
completely change the dynamic of video
because that's what people see when they
scroll on youtube that's that's what
they see
in that moment they decide then and
there if they're going to watch the
video based off of that fact
and that fact alone and so since then
i've
you know followed the same uh you know
same whatever and so i'll change
thumbnails and titles all the time and
it can change the dynamic of a video
yeah
that happened to our video yesterday we
posted it the original title was
real estate so bad real estate spiked
six percent is
the title was real estate spiked six
percent
my thoughts i posted it was the
worst performing video i've posted in a
long time and to the point where i'm
like is this
is this actually happening right right
this is gotta be a glitch
because it was so low and i'm like okay
it's
it's obviously the title so we change it
to
i forget like like the 2021 real estate
crash or something like that
i'll tell you right now because now it's
going to make some sense here it went
from real estate market
spiking six percent to like a real
estate calamity
real estate okay so real estate markets
spiked six percent
my thoughts change to the real estate
market just got worse
and it spiked you got a lot right didn't
it instantly yep
instantly it turned in from such a bad
performing video
to a really well performing video yeah
just really off that title change
yeah that's it it's crazy yeah and i do
that all the time because there's lots
of times i have a video like this was a
good video
yeah like it should be performing better
like people would enjoy watching this
video and it doesn't because of a poor
title thumbnail
and then you change it and then there
are other times like this is not a good
video i shouldn't do this
nobody should be watching this video and
then you change it anyways and it spikes
yeah yeah and sometimes you change it
and it does absolutely nothing
you know sometimes yeah usually i've
noticed after about
45 minutes to an hour is usually my like
whatever title you do it doesn't really
have an effect every now and then
um but i've actually i've changed titles
and thumbnails on videos like the day
later
right and have seen just the instant
switch up it's
crazy how that worked they were going to
call me out for this but here's the
thing
but really quick we have to thank
grammarly for the final sponsor of this
podcast
i cannot tell you the amount of times
i've struggled in my writing whether it
be for school
work or just a letter to a family member
well i recently got a grammarly premium
account and not only has the process of
writing gotten a lot easier but also my
writing has gotten
way more effective grammarly premium
helps evaluate your writing
through their really intuitive website
that provides clarity checks
vocab suggestions and advice on your
tone my favorite part of grammarly
premium is their goals feature where you
can get tailored writing advice based
off of your goals
and your audience for example i can
choose which tone i want to write in
and grammarly premium can adjust their
writing advice to reflect that tone
everyone always talks about walking the
walk or talking the talk
how about we write the right with
grammarly premium if you don't already
have grammarly premium i strongly
encourage you to try it out because it
has never been more important to have
clear
concise and effective writing evaluate
your writing with twenty percent off
grammarly premium at grammarly.com
slash iced coffee that's twenty percent
off grammarly g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee thank you guys
and enjoy the rest of the podcast
some of my videos are evergreen so i
could post a video today
and it's going to be the same video
today as it will be five years from now
so it's like the basic core principles
of how to invest
but for seo purposes i'll title that
video how to invest
in 2020 for beginners but it's the same
advice
right as you would say in 2015 is in
2030
so when the new year comes around how to
invest for
20 times why i never get text messages
back from you on new year's day
because you're changing all the titles
and thumbnails on those videos
yeah but it's incredible now i i never
did that like normally what i would do
is then just 20 21 would come around and
i and i know january is a busy month
because then i could remake all those
videos
how to invest in 2021 the best credit
cards of 2021.
it's it's just this green field this
blue sky of content
every january because oh absolutely yeah
you make the new videos yep
but i've had all these old videos that
were like so good that i felt bad and
you would just see 2021
right yep just change the title 2021
instantly they go back up one of my most
viewed videos now is something i made
like
two or three years ago and i just put
the 2020 in the title
and to this day it still and it's still
consistently
yeah it's the same thing i don't know in
the video like i'm going to show you
guys how to do this 2018
like the title right right but it's the
same thing so have you ever
deleted an old video and then
re-uploaded it like would you take one
of your 2018 videos
re-upload it on january 14th and just
change it and have
the exact same video different title i
have been so
tempted to try i've never done that i've
wanted to do that as an experiment
so badly i don't know if i could do that
but i've wanted to
the main reason i couldn't do that is
that my videos were so
bad back then really they're so awful so
cringy like if i go back two years ago
and i watched my videos like nope i
can't i can't do anything even if i go
back six months
you know i watch my old i don't know i
watch my older videos i'm like i
couldn't i would never want to re-upload
that but some of my viral videos from
years ago that are now dead
it's like man i just re-upload that like
a huge choosing you know
yeah you know what the only we've we've
reuploaded a few videos but
usually those are videos that have
issues in them and usually within 24
hours this is
right but i hate doing that when you
put you know post a video that first
hour oh those are all the people
that really make that video what it is
and then if you repost it
the day later sorry guys there's a
glitch in the video something happens
right uh none of those people come back
the second time
yep so it never does as well i can't
stand doing that or you have to really
change the title and thumbnail
so much that you need to re-get those
you have to get those people back yeah
but then those people click on the video
like wait
i watched this yesterday and then
they're like disappointed and then
they're kind of
i don't know and those are your most
loyal viewers those are who you create
content
for did my one of my cars fall did you
hear that
yeah i don't know what that was the gt-r
falling on the tesla
i mean
yeah yeah i was uh i was worried about
driving under that lift
because i've seen like final destination
and all those things and driving under
i'm like
this could be this is secure like if
this were to fall i was i had a game
plan what was your plan duck like as
soon as i heard a creep
as soon as i heard a creek i was gonna
so that's why when i looked over you you
like
yeah as soon as i was gonna do this and
i'm like how quickly can i open the door
if the car felt would it fall at an
angle or like right so wow
a lot of calculations went into this i
wasn't expecting to drive underneath
that thing so
you should have just gotten out of the
car before now that's fine let's take a
risk
but anyway what a risk taker but anyway
at some point i i do want to re-upload a
video and just see what what just
i'm just curious what do you think about
that idea obviously why not
i mean what do you what what's
worst-case scenario
what's the downside the algorithm i'm
always afraid of the algorithm
but like you create the thing is about
the algorithm like at the end of the day
you create good content that people want
to watch
people are gonna con you know like
that's that's what matters more than
anything more than the algorithm
you make good content people want your
content they're going to watch your
content
you know i don't know i believe in the
algorithm do you really
i see i am uh i am a i belie the
algorithm i don't think plays a role in
my success
i am forever indebted to the algorithm
so you think that
your channel success is because you've
got to be lucky with the algorithm and
somebody at youtube graham stefan i like
him algorithm
you i think it's about creating content
that does well from a from an algorithm
standpoint i think
i can make really good content but
without the titles and thumbnails like
you mentioned
of course you wouldn't do well but is
that because i think figuring out what
the algorithm wants
right and then creating content that i
like
that would also appease the algorithm is
really important
because i want to hit that demographic i
want the videos to do i want them to
have the biggest reach as possible so i
think right
learning what that algorithm is and then
crafting videos around it but the
algorithm is also dependent on like
click-through rates and stuff like that
so if you're changing the thumbnails and
stuff like that yeah you are playing to
the algorithm but at the same time
you're trying to
produce a thumbnail or a title that has
a better click-through rate so if
someone sees
this new tyler thumbnail they're more
compelled to click on it but it's seeing
then
which titles and thumbnails are being
clicked on what the algorithm is
recommending and then right
kind of shifting in that direction isn't
aren't more what you're talking about is
human psychology like when you change
the title thumbnails i don't do it for
the
algorithm no sometimes i do it for human
psychology i feel like there is an
algorithm that puts you in a box
and you you get within a certain range
like you've mentioned for your right
right within a certain view range when
you post a video i bet the first
hour you probably get almost the same
amount of people clicking in the first
hour
right a lot of the time yeah that first
five minutes the
same amount of people hit your video in
the first five minutes right
isn't that just statistics though no i i
can't imagine
when you have a sample size of let's say
three million people right
that you have a wide range of topics
that always
you're gonna get the same amount of
people clicking in the first five
minutes
it doesn't it doesn't make sense like
ideally i would think
some would be huge some would be little
but it wouldn't stay as consistent
right but like think about an instagram
story poll when you make a poll on
instagram
five minutes let's say the ratio is 40
60 after 20 minutes it's still 40 60.
it only fluctuates maybe a percent or
two but that's because you're getting
such a large sample size within the
first
five minutes once you get beyond let's
say a thousand two thousand people
that's a pretty good representation of
everybody in general
right yeah yeah yeah i mean that's how
they sample politics usually look at the
sample size of let's say a few thousand
people and they use that as a
representation for
but so i post my videos every single day
at noon
i have let's say three million subs to
make it easy don't you think roughly the
same amount of people
because it's an average everything i
feel like would fall upon an average
that means on average probably at noon
every single day of my three million
subs there's
a hundred to two hundred thousand of my
subs are on youtube
during that first hour and probably what
half of them are so clickbait
i think with the variances and titles
and subjects
right it should not stay so consistent
well i mean my videos do vary
from you know 900 000 to 1.5 million
they're not they're not consistently
always 1.1 1.1 points like so there are
there are i mean that's still a pretty
tight range it's not that tight though i
mean it's
that's a 50 i mean it's it's a decent
size experience
but i mean my my
thing on youtube has always been if you
make good videos that people want to
watch
the algorithm will like you because the
algorithm what are the key factors
watch time isn't watch time the most
important factor that's what that what
do you think it is
i think uh it's got to appeal to a broad
audience
right anyone can watch it and understand
it it's got to be appealing enough for
people to
see that in their feed and want to click
on it right and then
engage with the video okay so liking
comments so you think likes and comments
make a big difference i do
so my videos all be like oh if today's
video gets a hundred thousand likes you
know i'll do this
and lots of times i'll hit it and a
video will get a hundred thousand likes
and if i don't say anything let's say it
gets 50 000 likes
that video never gets more views and
never i've i've always found
on my end it helps really especially
comments
like i know within the first when i post
a video
i could tell how well it's going to do
based on how many people comment yeah
almost always in the first five minutes
see what it likes
my comments doesn't make a difference at
all some of my most viewed videos have
the least amount of comments
it might be different algorithms for
different creators though oh yeah yeah
i i don't think i could see that yeah
but don't you think at the end of the
day the
most important thing is if you film
content people want to watch
yeah i think logically it would be like
average view duration
and then the amount of people that are
recurring viewers absolutely recurring
is huge i think those yeah
probably like logically yeah that is
what i know like i like
if i like a creator i will continually
watch everything they put out and i will
watch it all the way through the end
oh for sure so youtube knows to
recommend that i just think of myself as
a viewer
what i get recommended and why i get
recommended those videos right and those
are basically the two main reasons
because i get recommended your videos
all the time and that's because
a while back i watched one of your
videos i watched the whole thing and
then i watched another one
and ever since then you've been
recommended and then when you post a
video i click
yeah so that reoccurring i think that's
at least from a subscriber sample
i think it's i think it's both but i
think a lot of it's marketing
mm-hmm just like you if you could have a
perfect product but if you have
terrible marketing for it no one's
absolutely try it but isn't that once
again just human psychology
marketing i mean in a sense well of
course like this algorithm
but then we're putting which is more
important is it marketing or having good
content
and i think for sure the algorithm i
think looks it looks at everything it
looks at first marketing and then
do people watch and like the video of
course of course
yeah i mean i i agree yeah marketing is
like
that's that's key maybe we're talking
about the same i think we are i think i
mean
algorithm i do think encompasses both
right i don't know i'm like
okay so sometimes i'll be talking to
other other creators and they'll be like
yeah
my videos just aren't getting very good
views the algorithm is just killing me
right now
and when they say that it sounds like
they're making an excuse
there's they're they're saying like my
video's not getting views because
someone at youtube doesn't like me
anymore
it's not because i need to make my
videos better but you know sometimes i
i've heard people say stuff like that
and i've seen their content i'm like
yeah no it makes sense why you're not
getting views
right it makes but it also makes its way
in algorithms not pushing this content
right because it's just it's not content
that i think
to stand behind yeah yeah yeah well i
don't think it's not necessarily good
content like
okay some of the content i feel like
this would not be a good
image for youtube to endorse okay well i
think that's kind of true
that's a difference that's a different
like is it yeah yeah i mean if we're
talking about like
can we say the word gun yeah you know if
we're talking about
about stuff like that yeah then yeah
absolutely
the algorithm plays a huge role for sure
but i'm thinking of just your average
family-friendly content you know like
what we create
you know and and when i think of other
creators who make the same
family-friendly content
sometimes i feel like they're they're
making excuses rather than just saying i
got to do better
you know like when they wake up the next
day like oh the algorithm is killing me
i don't want to post today instead of
thinking like i wake up i gotta go film
a cool video i gotta make my videos
better than the last video
honestly it's also a mindset thing it's
just by having that mindset you're more
likely to create content the algorithm
will like
yeah yeah yeah yeah who knows the
algorithm i think is your friend
that's whether or not you're right right
yeah
graham i think i think like the
algorithm was most in our favor
when we had the best content remember
like how you would say like oh back in
like april
it was so easy to make news oh because
there was
so much news in the finance community
and our algorithm was performing like
crazy but at the same time
i mean you didn't have to look very far
to you know
make a video about something because
there was news about literally
everything yeah
groundbreaking financing every single
day so at the same time it's like the
algorithm was
at its peak when there was the best but
that was
also the algorithm was working in
everyone's favor
because people were taking an interest
in personal finance so i think
youtube saw that that finance is a thing
right now that a lot of people
absolutely yeah
like okay we got these finance channels
let's give them more exposure now
because more people are interested so
then you have good content
in terms of of just reaching more people
how much do people want to hear about
the algorithm i'm worried now
yeah i think that yeah you know we
should talk about bugatti's
expensive cars spending money uh
spending money
yes spending money let me just say i'm a
spender today was my first time ever
sitting in a bugatti
and it was life-changing do you say
bugatti or bugatti
bugatti bugatti i think it's like okay i
probably completely messed that up
what about just boogity i say boogity
boogie
that's a nice way to put it how did it
feel it was low
and the seats were hard and uh as soon
as we he put the
the pedal to the metal that was when
things you know turned around
it was crazy i mean the intake was like
screaming
and and uh it just like felt like a rush
i was saying uh you know how like
disneyland has that
section like the california whatever
adventure oh yeah that roller coaster
you know california screaming the roller
coaster where they like
shoot you off he was saying like you
never get sick of it and i can see why
because it's like
i mean imagine having access to like
just the launch in california screaming
and you could just do it at whenever you
want like at your disposal
and so like i mean you pinned it like
four five
six times so much fun and it just got
more fun every time yeah yeah it is
crazy it makes me want to buy one yep
i'm gonna do it i'm not gonna get it
that car is dangerous because it can get
up to speed so quick i refer to it as go
to jail speed
and that would be anything basically
above 100 miles an hour and the car gets
to that speed so fast
it tempts you it's interesting on the
speedometer when you see it
the 100 is like on a normal car would be
like
40 miles an hour that's 100 on that car
yeah 100 is just like
barely like above zero sometimes it's
hard to know how fast you're going
because it goes
you know like the increments are so much
it goes 0 20 40 60. but it's all in like
you know just a tiny little section of
the speedometer right it's hard to gauge
like
wait am i going 40 am i'm going 20. it's
kind of weird yeah
but i find it most interesting driving
behind you
and watching all the reactions oh yes
especially oh my gosh that was
crazy there was uh we were driving to
the house
and there were two kids on the one side
by the sidewalk yep
and you drove by and they just froze for
a second
looked at each other like what what's
going on right now
and then there was like one second where
they didn't know what to do
they started running and they were like
trying to catch up with the car
yeah just to get a glimpse of it it
is uncomfortable it's exciting and very
nerve-wracking all at the same time
just because it it's i don't buy the
cars for the attention
i don't like the attention at all i love
the way the cars look i understand why
they get so much attention
but when you're on the freeway and
there's five cars circled around you and
every single person is holding a cell
phone filming you it's very
nerve-wracking because you're like
well what if the guy in front of me hits
his brakes and i got a break and the guy
filming me from behind rear-ends me you
know
so it's super nerve-wracking from that
standpoint and then you think about the
value attached to the car
and you think about the insurance
policies of all the other drivers
so like that part's really
nerve-wracking but then it's really fun
when you
go to a gas station and somebody's just
freaking out because they've never seen
a bugatti in their entire life
because this is the only veyron in utah
that i'm aware of there could be one
hidden you never know
but you know for most people here
they've never seen a bugatti in their
entire life
so those genuine reactions are pretty
fun as well and i totally get it because
when i was a 10 year old kid that's how
i would have reacted too so
it is fun and that's part of the reason
i drive my car so much
is growing up i never saw cool cars
so i just told myself if i ever
unfortunate to own a cool car i want to
share it with people
you know let people see it let people
sit in the car take photos take people
for rides
like that's always been a huge
motivating factor how often do people
ask what you do
it's weird most the people who see the
car know that i'm a youtuber okay
especially here in utah even there's a
lot of people who don't watch me but
they're still very familiar that i'm
here
you know oh you're the car guy with the
purple cars that's kind of how i'm
described as here in utah
because it's such a small community and
there's not that it's not like
california you know in hollywood there's
celebrities everywhere we're seeing utah
you know it's kind of more of a
tight-knit community there's not as much
going on and
if you've seen the purple bugatti once
you remember it and so people talk
um so a lot of people are are very
familiar with me and they know that i'm
a youtuber
you know i it's funny when i first got
the gallardo obviously that wasn't the
case and i would get that question asked
all the time
i don't think in the bugatti i've gotten
that question once at a time because
everybody
they're not familiar with you yeah
they're familiar
yeah and i like i've been featured a
couple times on the local like news and
stuff
for a while just for my cars and my
career and stuff
yeah this is yeah this is utah that's
basically like feature local people
occasionally like 31 year old buys
bugatti
that's basically a dollar title of the
artist
but this was back when it was i'd had
the event store i didn't have the
bugatti yet they reached out to me and
they want to do another one so
i need to do that that's fun yeah i know
it is fine it's cool it's kind of cool
yeah yeah super cute
do you ever do any like one of those
those make-a-wish things because i feel
like yeah bugatti i mean that would be
like uh in any kid's dream
oh definitely get a ride in that i've
never done specifically make a wish
foundation but i've done stuff very
simple okay
yeah and it's it's super cool i mean the
kids reactions are always really fun you
got to be you got to be cautious though
because
you know when you're taking a uh 10 year
old kid for a ride of bugatti you're not
going to go 150 miles an hour so you
give them the experience but
you don't go absurd speeds you know
imagine just just launching the car 200
miles an hour
getting one like a really good
experience
what's so like you know i've taken a lot
of kids for rides and you know they're
so content at
anything like because the car you know
when you're driving 25 miles an hour you
feel like you're in a spaceship
and you feel like you're going faster
than you're going half the time too so
usually you don't have to go 200 miles
an hour to get the 200 mile an hour feel
free
that would make a great viral video i've
seen some where it's uh what was the one
in the tesla
where they had the people for launch
control oh yeah yeah
reactions yeah yeah it's crazy though
like like we discovered today
you know the tesla launch is harder than
the bugatti yeah but it's the bugatti
you know around i don't know 25 30 miles
an hour those turbos kick in and it just
takes off yeah you know and that's
obviously pretty exciting yeah
so did we talk about how much the car
was in the podcast
i don't think so how much was i paid
eight hundred and eighty thousand okay
and i put down 580 and i financed 300
000. now when you had the 580
where was that money was that just
savings account yes sir
high interest savings account no sir why
because i knew that i was going to make
the purchase it
i generally make a purchase from a high
interest rate no i know i know i know i
know
um it's one of those things where i
generated the money fairly fast
and a lot of the money that i used to
for that 580 was from car sales
oh so i sold the ford gt i sold the c8
corvette i sold the super all very very
fast
and then i was on the hunt in the market
for the bugatti
i took all of the money from those
proceeds to buy the car
so it was like you know i took the money
put it in
the bank account and then i was waiting
to make a purchase at any given second
and i bought the car shortly after did
you feel financially comfortable
to buy the car or do you feel like you
kind of were stretching it a little bit
but you
knew it would pay off for the channel
yes and no
the channel provides the ultimate
justification
you know i know that i can film content
with the car
i can get you know a million two million
views per video
make you know ten fifteen thousand
dollars a video
and i knew you know i had just this list
of videos to film with the bugatti like
what we filmed today
you know this car is still pulling i
know the video we filmed today is going
to get good views
it's still pulling in those dividends
and so that helped a lot
i was really really thorough on the
process to buy the car it took me a long
time
and my audience was a little bit on edge
and a little bit frustrated because it
took
so long because buying a bugatti is not
an easy process i remember watching your
videos about this
yeah the hunt for the supercar how long
are you planning on holding on to the
bugatti for
i don't know i really really like the
car
and i see myself owning it for a long
time because i truly believe that the
bugatti veyron is at an all-time low in
value
like i see there's a certain group of
cars that are investment grade cars
they can have huge return on investment
and i see the bugatti as being one of
those cars because back in 2005
it represented performance like it
smashed every single record w16
quad turbo like the just the engineering
that went into that car is unparalleled
there's still not a car
quite like it like the sheer on as well
which is another bugatti but the sharon
is effectively a veyron as well like the
veron was the car
and when you look at the other hyper
cars for sale
the bugatti is such a great deal so i
think in five
10 years it could be worth double triple
what it is now and so i'd love to see
myself own the car and enjoy you know
those appreciation gains obviously i
could be completely wrong
you know the car could be half in value
but at the end of the day like it's a
bugatti they only built 450 of them
it's incredibly rare car it's a
collector car it's always going to be
worth
a significant amount of money so that's
that's part of the equation
obviously these cars can be a
maintenance nightmare and so if i get in
a situation where
the car starts breaking a lot i'm
getting repair bills of 40 50 000 bucks
and
the content's not doing good and there's
some other car that i have aspirations
to own i might sell it
walk us through some of the repairs uh
nick was telling me 21
dollars for an oil change yep 21 000 for
an oil change
so that's one of the big ticket items
obviously you have to do that once a
year
i think it's every 10 000 miles on it
though
or once a year so you have to do that
obviously you know you got to ship it to
a bugatti dealer which is san diego or
southern california how much exactly
ship it 1500 bucks okay probably
the tires on the car are crazy the oem
tires are
38 000 a set
just for the tires wow the wheels have
to be replaced every third tire change
and don't quote me on this but i think
they're 70 000 euros i don't know what
that exchange rate is wait a second wait
what do you mean you mean the rims have
to be replaced yeah why do the rims have
to be replaced so
the rims are glued to the tire
and the car is rated it's the difference
between the bugatti and every other car
it's rated to go 254 miles an hour so
every single component on the car
has to be engineered to withstand 254
miles an hour even if you're not driving
the car that fast
the wheel basically the structural
integrity of the wheel
they say every third tire change
is not efficient or whatever the word is
sufficient not sufficient
to withstand 254 miles an hour so every
third tire changes about 5 000 miles
so that means after three tire changes
that means you've driven 15 000 miles
so that means the wheels have endured 15
000 miles of rotation
so the structural integrity is not
sufficient to withstand 254 miles an
hour so they recommend replacing it
why not just not drive 250 miles so if
you if you were driving
under 120 yep and then you just like
every
10th absolutely and so i agree 100
so my car has aftermarket wheels and
tires that are
normal price you know the tires are too
grand to replace
the wheels are just normal wheels
they're not glued to the tire now i have
a set of the oem tires and wheels and if
i want to do a top speed run
i'll put those tires wheels on but you
know that might happen like you said
what once during ownership and i'll do
that now that's why the true
baller if you see a bugatti veyron
running around
on oem wheels and tires like you know
stock tires and wheels
that's the definition of a true baller
because he is rocking those prices
whereas obviously i'm rocking the
aftermarket because it just makes how
many people
do aftermarket on a bugatti like that
well you know
very few bugattis actually get driven so
450 veyrons let's say 75 in the united
states
a lot of the veyrons a lot of the owners
own multiple veyrons i know of a guy
in north america who owns six veyrons
why
that's the thing they're collector cars
i don't know i can't explain it
you know these guys they have hundreds
of cars that would be like 200
000 a year just in maintenance if you
don't even drive the car the thing
is those cars don't get driven they just
sit you know in a collection
yeah but even just changing the oil once
a year to sit in a collection they
do they don't just drain the oil really
they probably they
some possibly um obviously i can't speak
for every car but most
most of the cars you know don't really
get maintained or these guys just have
so much money they don't i mean if you
have six bugattis
yeah 100 car collections i don't know if
they really care that much
you know um so basically there's there's
very few
bugattis that are actually driven
because of that there's just very few
owners you know because a lot like the
guy that i bought this car from he had
another veyron
it's crazy like there's something about
the bugattis every single
nearly every single bugatti owner i know
has multiple bugattis
off the top of my head i don't know if i
can think of one
bugatti owner that only has one other
than myself i want to know more about
maintenance
i want to know how far will a bugatti
veyron go
like what's the the highest odometer
bugatti vey so bugatti had a press
veyron that had 60 000 miles on it
i think that's the highest that i know
of but my goal is to beat that
you yourself with this bugatti yup
that's the goal do a challenge
drive it and see how long you can drive
for before it runs out of gas
i thought about that but then i saw the
price of a replacement fuel pump on the
car
and i can't remember what it was but it
was jaw dropping
it was like five to ten thousand dollars
what mpg does it get eight
okay so driving normal how many gallons
normal but the car
if you have a full tank of gas and you
drive it foot to the floor it'll run out
of gas in 12 minutes
how many gallons can it hold it's
actually a big tank i think it's
25. it's a big tank
yeah that's always a big tank yeah yeah
it's a really big tank you
could have one of the most viral youtube
videos driving my bugatti veyron across
the united states
i want to do that on my list i want to
go and i want to camp the whole way
that would be that's it no that's that's
something that i want number one on
trending
that would be uh how could anyone not
watch that
how could anyone not watch that video
didn't danny duncan do something like
that oh he hitchhiked
danny duncan hitchhiked across the
united states from florida to california
so cool
uh and did it uh then arac
did what was that he took a scooter yeah
he took us
he took a fiat or no a smart car or
something yeah something like that
if you did the road trip at the bugatti
yeah anything road trip
anywhere just every video is a new road
trip to a new place in that current camp
yeah yeah or picking up hitchhikers i've
been wanting to do that
[Applause]
my jeep gladiator has been converted to
a 6x6 so it's gonna be like this crazy
monster truck
and it's purple as well so my plan is to
do the uber video with the bugatti and
the gladiator
because in the event that you you know
roll up just like and i want to
genuinely do it i do not
fake any of my videos i don't set it up
i don't get a girl to
you know pick her up and have her oh
surprise she's not wearing any clothes
you're like
that's not my style her shirt literally
comes off as you're driving
it's all everything yeah nearly every
uber video is just a complete yeah i
want to actually genuinely do it
yeah because you actually have to sign
up for uber i doubt that these people
actually have made accounts
gotta prove to be a driver no usually
what they do is they use someone else's
car
and then they pull up and pull up yeah
yeah yeah so the pen would be to get the
jeep as the
actual uber but then roll up in the
bugatti in the jeep and then so if you
end up picking up a party of four
you know one person riding the bugatti
in the other in the sixth sixth jeep
so that's a future uber video that i
want to film for that would be fun
yeah yeah so i mean the goal for this
car is to you know hit those viral
videos because
one viral video can it can change
the whole dynamic of a channel it's
crazy how much do you make from those
videos
can we talk about income videos um
viral videos you i mean ad revenue is
generally not as good on viral videos
obviously because loyal viewers watch
more at the video they watch more of the
ads
you just earn way more but um
i mean per video on average
hmm do i want to say that i don't know
i've already said it they already said
it you said it on the main channel oh i
did it not on the podcast oh
uh probably like seven eight grand i'd
say on average per
now obviously december it's a little
higher yeah january maybe a viral video
no just for like my normal like one
million one million view video
yeah which is yeah that adds up to a lot
over
a year yeah no it does it does this is
this has got to be your highest
earning year oh absolutely yeah yep yep
it's gone higher
every single year has it gone higher
month on month this year
so my best month of all time was
september
of 2020 and then my second
best month second bus month i think was
when was that it was it was in 2019.
um i had oh it was supra it was super
2019 august 2019
that was a big month and then my third
best month was november but i'm i think
i'm gonna
so it's generally an aperture it's
definitely an upwards can you share what
you made in that september
like adsense um it was a hundred and
thirty five thousand dollars that's what
it takes to own a bugatti yeah yeah
yeah wow that's like so that's like five
oil changes right
yeah and i didn't i did have to do an
oil change in september yeah now
september was the month that i bought
the bugatti
so obviously those first videos did very
very well yeah so as expected i mean
i would hope that if i spent that much
money on a car september would do me
well and it did
you know the the video unveiling the car
has like two
i don't two and a half million views i
did another race video that has two and
a half million views from that month
yeah so i got a couple big videos off
the car and those videos you know a lot
of those videos
over time that's the great thing about
youtube you know you're investing in
your future yeah like my video buying
the aventador
i think that video has four or five
million views you know it got a million
views in the first couple months and now
it has five million
so i hope that the bugatti videos
obviously continue yeah
to spark interest yeah what percentage
of your views
are from older videos versus newer
videos like month
right yes every month almost all newer
videos
yeah it's uh like if when you look at my
adsense graph
it's just like a huge spike when i post
sam yeah it's just like
yeah and you maybe have like five or ten
videos that will consistently do well
over time yeah yeah exactly a couple of
my viral videos from years ago you know
i still pull in a couple hundred bucks a
month off of those
which is cool but it's it's all the new
content if i stop
posting i don't know i'm gonna be like
20
yeah i'd say 20 yeah so i'd probably
make but i would imagine there'd be
you know after the first month the
second month would probably be worse i
could probably just
continue so in six months i would wonder
i've always
wondered but obviously like that's not
something you can test i've always
wondered how much money would i make if
i just quit youtube
how much would i continue to earn every
month yeah i've looked at similar
channels that have stopped uploading
and it seems like they they all hit a
base where they just kind of
hover at that level um there was another
youtuber who took the year off and he
made a hundred thousand dollars
wow yeah not even a big channel um
i think he he has like 200 000 um od
productions
but he made a video of how much he made
taking the year off of making videos
that's pretty cool
but a hundred grand and he has 200 000
subscribers
but he does e-commerce so like obviously
his cpm was like 70. like yeah yeah yeah
insane yeah but still was interesting
but what i find interesting for you is
that
despite making that much money i mean
your overhead is very low
very low you have no employees nothing i
spend money on
nothing it's never all just goes to cars
yeah basically yeah savings and cars
yep yeah i have a i have uh you know
this house that i'm building so i'm
obviously i have the down payment
you know for that but yeah savings i
mean i i buy
you know i bought the gtr in november i
bought the aventador roadster in october
i bought the bugatti in september
that's the thing i've now reached the
point where i don't have any car
purchases on the horizon
but sometimes opportunities do present
themselves you know last minute so if
next week i'm buying a car
i don't i don't know about that right
now but things can change really really
quick
if you had to buy a car by the end of
the year yes
what would you buy mark for supra it's
another
it's a jdm car um i'd love to and it's
just such a cool car i had the mark 5
supra that i sold to jeffy star
and 50 grand for the yeah
yeah yeah and once again you know
looking at it from an roi standpoint
that car would crush it
you know as 50 grand versus yeah 900
on the bugatti so i think that i think
that car is definitely in the future
but we'll see what happens have you
thought about hiring an employee
yes i have i have and
one thing that i truly love about what i
do
is my freedom i have so much freedom and
freedom is so
valuable and it makes me so happy i
don't
want stress in my life stress isn't
worth it stress
yeah i don't want it in my life having
an employee
could relieve stress but i could also
see it creating a bunch of stress
and you have to find somebody that you
trust because you're
opening up your entire life to this
person and they could
they could mess up some stuff pretty bad
and so it's like is
it worth it are the you know the
increased
you know prop increased profit uh you
know
decrease in stress is it worth that risk
yeah i don't know here's the thing
here's the way i've started to look at
it is that you don't look at
an employee let's just say as an
increase in profit yeah you're buying
your time back
right right that's really what it is if
that person saves you 20 hours a week
right what's that worth to you to have
an extra 20 hours a week to do whatever
you want
that's the thing i love what i do yeah i
love every aspect of it
i love creation i love editing i love
the cars i love the filming
and i actually enjoy the logistics like
when we were out at the track today
and i was setting up cameras and telling
people you getting that car i just
i like it yeah i don't it's weird like i
have
i have the time to basically do most of
stuff that i do
um the one thing about filming it takes
a lot of
energy out of me i don't want to be
filming every day that's not what i want
i like filming once every other day
once every three days like the days when
i'm doing other stuff it's kind of sort
of relaxing
and it's actually good for me it's like
yesterday you know i was ubering picking
up tesla's picking up cars you know
answering text messages
i kind of like it yeah and what about
now you have a relationship
i do you got a strad girl yes i'm dating
tessa you're dating tessa does she like
being in the youtube videos
she want to be on camera yes and no
she doesn't really care which is one
thing that i like about her
she's happy to be on the channel but
she's happy to be her own person too
you know i never wanted i never wanted
the channel to become tessa and i
with cars um i don't want our
relationship
to get mixed up in youtube fame because
i know of some other creators that have
had relationships
and you know youtube their audience
loves their relationship and then
behind the scenes they're they're not
very happy together and then eventually
they break up
and then you know youtube it's all this
drama and they have to make up the you
know make these breakup videos
it's not what i want like i care about
tessa i want tessa to date
james i don't want tessa to date
stradman sure and so she's in the videos
here and there occasionally you know but
she has her own life you know she works
her own job she's busy in school as well
and so i kind of like hanging out
and not be working yeah you know when i
hang out with tessa
she gets 100 of my attention i like that
you know is there anything else you want
to
mention any final words of wisdom thank
you guys for having me thank you for
coming to utah
i had a blast this is fun it was really
really fun day
you know if you guys find yourself up in
the area again you know
when it's warm it's not going to be it's
not going to be anytime soon no
it's warm it's not gonna be warm any
time soon either yeah
maybe next year may or just like the
summer is hot up here too that's what's
crazy
we get all four seasons come to vegas
though after january
yeah yeah yeah no i'm in vegas i'm in
vegas all the time cool
yeah come to vegas yeah look at our legs
guys
yeah it was only a matter of time until
we all
it was you know the same thing all right
like now we're in rhythm
all right jack anything else we need to
no i think we're good all right
um so i'll do the outro so with that
said you guys thank you so much for
watching i really appreciate it thank
you so much for doing this this has been
a blast i'm exhausted but we're
where are we going the texas texas
roadhouse texas roadhouse we're
celebrating tonight so
that's where we're going so thank you
guys so much for watching make sure to
subscribe i'll link to your information
down below in the description
our instagrams are there where also you
could get four free stocks
the offer is still going i think we're
gonna be posting this in time before the
offer expires you get four free stocks
use that link down below in the
description it's worth it it's basically
free money so if you like free money use
that link down below in the description
thank you so much for watching and
until next time say destroy the like
button oh yeah wait what
smash the like button crush it kill it
look at this camera and say
make sure to destroy the like button and
if you could please make sure to just
destroy the like button i'd appreciate
it graham would appreciate it even more
thanks guys see ya
cameras or should we just look at each
other and or talk as well
oh look at each other look at each other
act like the cameras aren't there wait
so if we look at each other
wait are we already starting
okay so we live the coming seconds like
the
the 30 seconds before we start the
podcast i throw it in at the end
oh so it shows like the build up i see i
see i see yeah
so this is going to be an episode just
at the end oh okay so it's like welcome
to the 30th ever episode welcome to the
30th episode
ever of the third ever
just say welcome to the 30th ever
episode of the ice coffee hour
my name is james and so far this podcast
is made wait say that again
this is a lot of pressure i like how
it's like makes the guest mildly
uncomfortable right after does every
single guest
react this way yeah a lot of them don't
get it right so it's all good